- Do you do this ranch
in pizza abomination?
- No, I don't.
I have a fully developed taste palette,
so I don't have any need to dip my pizza
into ranch dressing.
- Today we're trying
something revolutionary.
- Is it?
- I don't know.
It's kind of gross.
It's ranch dressing on a pizza.
- I used to love ranch as a kid
but I haven't had it recently.
- Same.
I used to have it in middle school
and I can't remember having it since then.
- It's a thing we do
with like mid grade chain
and or freezer pizza.
- Exactly.
- I don't think it's a
thing you do with pizza.
- Yeah, there's like pizza
and then there's pizza.
- Are we pizza snobs?
- Yeah.
- I'm not one to do this
because I don't like ranch dressing.
But I do know it's
something that people love.
- The only thing, pizza I don't like
is gummy bears and sardines.
- Have you had gummy bear pizza?
- No but it doesn't sound good.
- I could go for it.
- Tada.
- I love pizza.
- This is a good example of pizza
that I would not think of
dipping in ranch dressing.
- Yeah.
- This is like decent pizza
that taste very good on it's own.
- Alright.
- I'm open minded.
- I'm just going all out.
That looks so gross.
- Oh, it's dripping.
What if I throw up?
- I'm not that nervous.
This is a pretty tame endeavor.
- I really wanted to like it.
- I don't like it.
- It's not like awful or disgusting.
It's just like the pizza
is fine on it's own.
- It's good.
I feel it's healthy 'cause
it feels like when you dip
carrots into ranch, it
kind of taste like that.
- Yeah, I feel like we're
eating carrot sticks
but a carby version.
- Right now I'm falling
somewhere between neutral
and positive.
Like either it's not adding anything
or it's adding like a nice
little something that I like.
I just can't tell.
I'm conflicted.
- It's too much.
Too many flavors.
- I hate it.
- It's a good way to ruin a pizza.
- I kind of like the coolness
of the ranch on the pizza.
I feel like adds a new layer.
- I would argue that it's overpowering.
I taste more ranch than pizza
and then I feel like that kind of defeats
the purpose of pizza.
- I stake a large part
of my reputation in.
Oh, you are ...
Your face is lighting up.
- Guys.
- I'm nerve.
- I think this is actually really good.
- I wouldn't go out of my way to get it
but if I was sitting at a
table and there was pizza
and there was some ranch I
might dip a couple bites in.
- I like ranch, so I'm into it
and especially if you have a spicy bite,
like this would like cool it down.
- Honestly I think what I'm experiencing
is a really good just bread dipping sauce.
Like if you had some garlic
breads and cheesy garlic bread,
then you've got yourself a time.
- That's absolutely what it is.
- Then you got something going.
- It's the bread in the ranch.
It's not pizza in ranch.
It's bread in ranch.
And the crust is close enough.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't make it better.
It makes it different.
Sometimes you wanna try something new.
- So, I think it was really
interesting to try the ranch
with pizza and for me that
just opens up the door
to trying more sauces with pizza,
like hot sauce with pizza
and honey with pizza,
maybe even Arby's sauce with pizza.